c'est le premier compteur linky
installés dans le département des
yvelines
le 3 mai à maule erdf a lancé le
déploiement de son nouveau compteur
intelligent
l'objectif équipé 90 % du territoire
français en remplaçant 35 millions de
compteurs sur les cinq prochaines années
linky est un compteur électrique de
nouvelle génération qui va apporter à un
grand nombre de services nouveaux à nos
concitoyens et leur permettent de faire
des économies sur leurs factures et des
économies d'énergie sur le territoire
des yvelines on remplacera 650000 un peu
plus de 650000 compteur à l'horizon
également en 2021 pour la première année
le déploiement commencera autour de
trois zones
les mureaux saint quentin en yvelines et
vélizy pour s'étendre progressivement
sur le reste du département
la pose du compteur ne nécessite que 30
minutes et sera effectué par des
entreprises locales partenaires de erdf
linky pendant la période de pause qui
s'échelonne jusqu'en 2021 va créer dix
mille emplois en france 5000 pour la
construction des compteurs l'ensemble
des compteurs sont construits sont
montés en france sont assemblés en
france
et puis 5000 emplois qui vont être
dédiés à la pause pour erdf line qui
permet de piloter son réseau plus
efficacement à distance pour le client
c'est l'opportunité de mieux gérer sa
consommation d'énergie en la suivant
directement sur internet
tout ce qui permet de réduire un peu sa
consommation est positif puis on a
l'habitude maintenant des éléments
communiquant à table est le téléphone
donc ça fait partie du du parcage
standard maintenant de l'habitat
vraiment le but pour moi c'est de
pouvoir aller sur internet de savoir
quasiment à l'instant t combien je
consomme et par-delà anticipé un peu ma
consommation et de voir la note
effectivement effective à payer aucun
changement n'est à effectuer sur
l'installation électrique ou les
appareils ménagers pour éviter tout
démarchage frauduleux erdf insiste sur
le fait que l'installation du compteur
est notifié aux clients par courrier au
minimum un mois al avance